[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we've got some stunning
news for you about the ongoing russia
investigation news that will challenge
everything you thought you knew about
this story yesterday we showed you the
terrifying extent to which Vladimir
Putin's sinister tendrils have encircled
the American body politic crushing the
very life from this Republic Russian
agents are so intent on undermining our
democracy they have taken to promoting
our own bill of rights back to us the
Second Amendment specifically now will
admit we're not exactly sure how that's
bad but Adam Schiff has assured us that
it is and because Schiff is a prominent
member of Congress and often appears on
cable news we believe him now tonight
we've learned that the foreign
subversion goes even deeper than that
the Russian conspiracy is so subtle so
crafty such a bewilderingly vac Hall of
Mirrors
that the very people warning us about
Russia are in fact key players in the
Russian conspiracy the leaders of the
witch-hunt are witches sound impossible
listen to this last year the Director of
National Intelligence released the
definitive report on Russian propaganda
efforts in this country the main focus
of that report was the Russian cable
channel RT America which is funded and
controlled by the Putin government in
the words of our intelligence community
arts he engages in and recording now
anti us messaging likely aimed at
undermining viewers trust in US
democratic procedures and quote our
government considers our t so dangerous
that the channel has been forced to
register as a foreign agent artsy
employees who failed to register could
face prison time no outlet in this
country has ever been forced to do that
RT is a sinister place everybody says so
so who would go on a channel like that
one whose sole agenda is to discredit
and destroy the American experiment well
none other than one Adam Bennett Schiff
of Burbank California you know him as
congressman Adam Schiff the ranking
Democrat on the House Intelligence
Committee the man leading the charge
against Vladimir Putin's propaganda
machine and yet Adam Schiff was part of
that machine
seriously